bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
jean marc a est mort il allait avoir 85
ans cinéma théâtre peinture céramiste
écrivain jean marais comme jean cocteau
avec un talent multiple il répétait je
ne suis pas un artiste je m'amuse jean
tulard historien du cinéma nous donnera
son analyse de la place de jean marais
dans le cinéma français
l'ouragan mitch a entraîné la mort ou la
disparition de près de trente mille
personnes lors de son passage au
nicaragua au honduras au salvador et au
guatemala
les villages sont engloutis les voies de
communication sont détruites
l'économie de ces pays est gravement
atteinte l'aide internationale arrive
difficilement nous vous proposeront des
reportages avec les récits des rescapés
les témoignages des sauveteurs nous
serons en direct de managua capitale du
nicaragua de tegucigalpa au honduras
avec nos différentes équipes d'envoyés
spéciaux à cette tragédie en amérique
centrale nous consacrerons l'essentiel
de cette édition jusqu'à 21h avec tous
les journalistes de la rédaction de
france 2 qui se trouve actuellement sur
place jean marais était un homme modeste
il prétendait avoir été privilégiés
toute sa vie s'était amusé disait-il il
s'était amusé au cinéma au théâtre et
depuis 1981 à vallauris en devenant
peintre sculpteur décorateur il aurait
eu 85 ans le 11 décembre prochain
il est mort hier dans un hôpital de
cannes ainsi disparaît définitivement
celui qui fut tout à la fois la belle et
la bête
imaginé par jean cocteau paradoxalement
jean marais la beauté même a connu la
gloire sous le masque de la bête en 1946
la bête n'est plus c'était moi j'ai
compris très vite que le cinéma me
permettait de faire ce que je voulais au
théâtre parce que le cinéma m'a fait
connaître à monseigneur robotique aussi
familière faudra que je te fasse trop
c'est un jour pour des aubergines hausse
à monseigneur ma boss ne porte bonheur
question à la caresse coutume à bosch
montilla
je me suis beaucoup amusé le passé est
mort vive la gare et des films de cape
et d'épée jean marais on tournera une
dizaine nez de cuir le capitan le
capitaine fracasse sans jamais être
doublé beaucoup d'acteurs ranvier tous
les ans et minéraux de cirque au gala de
nyon
cette année-là en 1958 il fit un
triomphe au sommet d'un réverbère qui
lui valu de nombreux engagements dans
les films d'action
ce qui ne l'empêchait pas de tourner
parallèlement des films romantiques
comme la princesse de clèves qui est il
est malade c'est ta mére qui vous donne
cette crête
depuis quand betty qu'at-il fait pour
plaire que chemin at il trouvé pour
aller à votre coeur
sa carrière éblouissante jean marais la
doite à celui qui fut son amant son ami
son père spirituel
jean cocteau en lui offrant le rôle de
michel dans les parents terribles
il imposa au théâtre
on en est et adore et papaleo peu mais
la fed a comme un drame maman voulait
rappeler la police me faire arrêter la
folie
pourquoi ça c'est le style du moment
le style de la chambre de leurs skis
mais m'a projetée en avant qui m'a qui a
aidé à toute ma carrière longue et riche
carrière théâtrale qui le conduira ces
dernières années jusqu'à cette puissante
composition du roi lear de shakespeare
et marche est il assez ou et savoir 16e
où son esprit massy où son discernement
et tambours les quoi je me prends pas du
tout bon un artiste je place les
artistes allemands où je ne peux
imaginer en être un moi-même et mais je
m'amuse
moi je peins je dessine je sculpte je
fais de la boxe et un à pied long que
j'ai fait ici dans ma chambre c'est à
l'univers cocteau jean cocteau partout
cocteau dont j'ai fait le con traîne là
ce sont les mains de cocteau aussi
les deux mains on peut en être sûr jean
marais s'en est allé rejoindre jean
cocteau au paradis des monstres sacrés
il ne s'agit pas de comprendre
il s'agit de croire
george v go une georges bigot vient de
nous retracer quelques-uns des grands
moments de la carrière cinématographique
théâtrale artistique de jean marais mais
cet homme qui avait le goût du bonheur
et l'élégance d'avouer ses défauts cet
artiste dont le président jacques chirac
salue ce soir les qualités de loyauté et
de fidélité et de générosité
ce comédien qui fut tout à la fois poète
et cascadeur a essayé toute sa vie
d'être simplement heureux commentaires
antoine cormery dans l'album de
souvenirs que nous laisse jean marais
voici l'un de ses derniers moments au
milieu d'un public qui lui a tant donné
c'était en mai dernier sur la côte
d'azur à vallauris l'hommage de la ville
à l'un de ses grands hommes
je suis toujours étonné que parce que
vous me traitez comme si j'étais à
l'artiste et moi je plaçais l'artiste
chiot il y en a beaucoup à vallauris
jeune que ça me prend pour un artiste je
suis un vieux monsieur de 85 ans qui
continue à s'amuser s'amuser voilà le
mot qui a tant compté dans la carrière
de celui qui était pourtant bel et bien
un artiste aux talents multiples la
preuve le traité est prêt si l'auto
portrait fidèle il y a un an sur nos
plateaux il se livrait de bonne grâce à
son exercice préféré
après le théâtre mais cette quête du
bonheur face est avant tout par la scène
où il jouait encore en mars 97
l'arlésienne aux folies bergères il
répondait consciencieusement courrier de
ses admirateurs avant d'entrer en scène
comment faire de la ville
la petite chèvre de monsieur seguin
qui fait ma dernière performance
d'acteur ça ira très bien avec mama
invraisemblable c'est un homme qui je
trouve le plus où j'ai la chance de le
connaître
me paraissait toujours comme un enfant
étonné de son propre destin
ce n'était pas un homme du tout qui
avait fait ce trajet et qui prétendait
l'avoir faire ils étaient étonnés et
comme un enfant et c'est sans des parm
nous touche beaucoup et quand j'ai
rencontré cet homme je me suis aperçu
que le héros du cinéma était aussi un
héros dans la vie quoi voilà c'est un
homme qui avait toutes les qualités à la
fois sur l'écran mais dans la vie et il
s'est comporté pendant le tournage des
misérables comme quelqu'un qui faisait
son premier film quoi on n'avait pas
imaginé qu'il avait un tel passé
cinématographique c'était une légende
et c'est vrai qu'il a fait rêver la
france entière pendant cinquante ans que
l'album de souvenirs se referme donc sur
ces photos en noir et blanc témoignages
éternelle une carrière d'un demi siècle
à
oh
moi
les obsèques de jean marais auront lieu
vendredi et valorise depuis son décès
hier l'hôpital des broussailles à cannes
de nombreuses réactions évidemment de
sympathie ont été diffusées jean-marie
vivait dans la cité des potiers de
vallauris depuis 18 ans cette ville
respectera quatre jours de deuil
sur france 2 dès demain soir les
programmes seront modifiés pour rendre
hommage à jean marais avec à 20h50
demain le bossu d'andré hunebelle le
film date de 1959 suivi à 22h55 du
capitan le film du même réalisateur
c'était en 1960
et puis d'un bouillon de culture de
bernard pivot enregistrée il ya près de
deux ans et enfin samedi à 7 heures
l'émission de catherine ceylac thé ou
café avec jean barrès enregistrée il ya
18 mois sera rediffusé jean tulard
bonsoir vous êtes historien être
l'auteur d'un dictionnaire du cinéma et
vous écrivait notamment compo de jean
marais et fut longtemps le plus
populaire des jeunes premiers il est
resté c'est vrai assez longtemps une
sorte de symbole de vie de jeunesse de
force s'enthousiasme de bukavu dans sa
carrière c'est le jeune premier il est
le jeune premier dans l'éternel retour
il est encore le jeune premier dans les
fantômas d'une belle où il fait à la
fois fantômas et le journaliste fandor
le jeune journaliste par rapport au
vieux commissaire juve qui interprète
louis de funès
donc c'est un acteur qui a comme emploie
toujours le jeune premier mais ce n'est
pas un jeune premier comme les autres il
y à différents jeune premier qui l'a
interprété il y a le jeune premier de
l'éternel retour c'est le romantisme
dans les ces années noires des pacsés
temps 43 dans une période où la jeunesse
est déchiré persécutés affamés et il
symbolise l'espoir et puis il y eut
ensuite la période cocteau qui est une
période post surréaliste où la rêve
continue l'imaginaire c'est l'imaginaire
et puis il y à ce qui a été sa grande
période et je ne peux que féliciter
antenne de masse est véritablement deux
films majeurs qui sont mineures dans
l'accident graphie française mais qui
serait non les assises annuelles design
et innovation les meilleurs à savoir
notamment le capitan on aurait pu passer
aussi lé capitaine fracasse dont et le
bossu et c'est là où l'on peut se rendre
compte de son génie parce que ces rôles
il a interprété d'autres les âmes et
interpréter avant lui ou les ont
interprétés avec michael douglas
fairbanks si vous prenez par exemple
bossue vous avez prendre six versions du
bossu vous avez la version pierre
blanchard pierre blanchard est un grand
acteur ce n'est pas le bossu il est
rigide
vous avez eu récemment la version daniel
auteuil qui est un merveilleux acteur
mais qui n'est peut-être pas le bossu
c'est à dire que lagardère lagardère ira
à toi celui là au personnage de duc de
nevers s'est effectivement je marais et
si vous prenez son interprétation
admirable du comte de monte cristo c'est
un remake de robert vernet vous comparez
avec l'interprétation de depardieu de
partir d'un immense acteur mais il n'a
pas ce mystère cette beauté cette
élégance qui vous expliquent le succès
du comte de monte cristo dans la société
de la monarchie de juillet parce que
jean marais a à la fois un mystère
une distinction une élégance qui ne
pouvait que séduire aussi bien procureur
du roi qu'un monde de la chambre des
pairs et en cela même il incarne une
vengeance beaucoup plus déroutante que
s'ils avaient été les alors les il l'a
été car c'est un c'est un jeune premier
qui fait tous les emplois il peut être
le méchant dans fantômas puisqu'ils
étaient à la fois fandor et fantômas
mais il peut être aussi la bête avec ce
maquillage
christian est magnifique merci
jeantulien avant d'ouvrir nos pages
spéciales consacrées à la catastrophe en
amérique centrale voici les principales
informations de cette journée comme tous
les 9 novembre date anniversaire de la
mort du général de gaulle différentes
cérémonies ont eu lieu à colombey les
deux églises
outre le président la république des
parlementaires du rpr sont venus se
recueillir 28 ans après sur la tombe du
général
à cette occasion le débat sur la
réhabilitation des soldats de 14-18
révolter contre ceux qui les envoyait au
carnage le débat politico historique à
remonter reportage j'évite imbert jean
piat pasteur la période est riche en
anniversaires et en symboles ce matin
jacques chirac s'incliner devant la
tombe du général de gaulle mort il ya
tout juste 28 ans hommage à l'homme du
18 juin 40 tandis que s'amplifie la
controverse au sujet de l'autre grands
conflits du siècle
14-18 inopportun avait fait savoir le
chef de l'état parlant des propos de
lionel jospin sur les fusillés du chemin
des dames déplacer renchérissent les
députés rpr sur le quai de gare qui les
mène à colombey-les-deux-églises le
premier ministre fait une erreur mais
nous savons depuis longtemps que c'est
un bien piètre historien et dans le
train le pèlerinage prend des allures
martiales
c'est philippe séguin qui mène la charge
déjà très mécontents à propos du débat
sur le pacs il est encore plus furieux
au sujet de la polémique sur les mutinés
tout particulièrement contre françois
hollande qui a suggéré d'autres
réhabilitation s'agissant de la de vichy
alors il s'agissait aussi de réhabiliter
les coiffer mais c'est son parti les
gens qui ont adhéré au parti dedans il y
aurait été à même à droite pourtant il
ya débat alors que hier valéry giscard
d'estaing trouvais justifiée les
déclarations de lionel jospin au rpr
aussi certains veulent faire la part des
choses
les fusillés pour l'exemple de la guerre
de 14 18 moi je me souviens que mon
grand père qui était un ancien 14,8 m'en
parlait un jour l'autre il faut
dire quelque chose à leur égard
maintenant qui doit le dire la réponse
est simple pour les gaullistes c'est
jacques chirac et lui seul qui aurait dû
s'exprimer sur ces questions
a colombes et comme à paris c'est de
l'histoire de france que se nourrit
aujourd'hui le débat politique est le
premier ministre lionel jospin s'est
déclaré surpris par les effets de sa
déclaration sur les mutineries 1917 il
s'exprime est à lyon aujourd'hui j'ai
été surpris par cette polémique à mon
sens elle n'avait pas lieu d'être
d'ailleurs tous les documents qui ont
été publiés depuis les témoignages les
historiens la façon de se sont exprimés
les quelques survivants du chemin aux
dames ont montré que tout simplement
j'avais dit des choses humaines juste et
nécessaire
je n'ai rien à dire de plus le débat sur
le pacte civil de solidarité pacs qui a
été interrompu à l'assemblée nationale
la nuit dernière après l'adoption d'une
partie seulement de l'article premier du
texte ce débat reprendra les 1er et 2
décembre prochain c'est la proposition
du gouvernement qui ne veut pas ainsi
reculé devant l'obstruction menée par
l'opposition de droite
le ministre de l'agriculture monsieur
jean glavany obtenu satisfaction auprès
de la commission européenne à bruxelles
dans sa demande d'un programme spécial
d'exportation de viande porcine en
faveur de la russie
cent mille tonnes de viande de porc
serait ainsi exporter sport voile route
du rhum les premières difficultés n'ont
pas tardé compte tenu de la mauvaise
météo le bateau accompagnateur d'olivier
de kersauson a été endommagé par la
foudre c'est le français paul vatine qui
lui a pris la tête de cette sixième
course du rhum commentaires christophe
du chien
paul vatine fait route vers l'ouest et
pour l'instant ça lui réussit le normand
occupe la tête du classement multicoque
mais pour lui comme pour les autres les
premières heures de course n'ont pas été
une partie de plaisir
les rafales de vent et une mer formée un
bateau difficile à manoeuvrer
la nuit dernière a été agitée 40 km
devant ces bateaux là tiennent plus
bien sûr le formula c'est à dire on est
quasiment toujours en suis en vie c'est
vrai que cette nuit très vite à bord du
soc d'europe ça a été le clou à que mes
affaires fake sont venus se répandent
par terre pour tenir lieu de serpillière
j'ai moi-même eu mal de mer et des trois
autres au large des premières
indications en observant la carte chez
les multicoques ici en rouge les options
se dessinent entre ceux qui ont choisi
l'ouest comme gatineau guillemot et ceux
qui sont plus au sud comme joyau
bouriaud perron mais il faudra attendre
48 heures pour établir un premier bilan
pour savoir qui a vu le plus clair dans
le jeu de la météo
contre mauvaise fortune mike birch
l'ancien vainqueur de la route du rhum
obligé de faire une escale technique à
brest suite à une petite avarie
c'est pas grand chose mais si c'est rien
je suis un peu heureusement pour lui à
16 heures après réparation le
flegmatique canadien reprenait la course
en revanche pour yvan bourgnon la course
est terminée
le mât de son trimaran s'est effondré
hier soir et ce matin ce qui reste de
son bateau est arrivé à perros-guirec
épreuve impitoyable la route du rhum qui
ne pardonne pas de faiblesse ni à
l'homme ni à la machine littérature une
journée de prix le prix goncourt est
allé à paul constante tenu le prix
france télévisions en mai dernier donc
présenté pour cette femme écrivain de
son roman confidence pour confidence qui
était publié chez gallimard
c'est une réflexion sur cinq siècles
l'évolution des femmes réflexion avec
des fonds féminin le prix renaudot lui a
été attribuée à dominique bona pour son
roman le manuscrit de porc et ben ça se
passe à saint domingue
c'est publié chez grasset voilà compte
tenu de l'extrême gravité des
conséquences du passage du cyclone mitch
en amérique centrale nous avons décidé
ce soir de vous proposer jusqu'à 21h des
reportages
des témoignages pour mieux comprendre la
situation actuelle au nicaragua au
honduras au salvador et au guatemala
c'est sans doute l'une des plus grandes
catastrophes naturelles de la moitié du
siècle
trente mille personnes mortes ou
disparues et des millions de sans abri
on continue aujourd'hui encore de
retrouver les cadavres et les survivants
espère des secours au salvador et au
guatemala les effets du cyclone ont
provoqué également des victimes et des
dégâts mais dans la comptabilité macabre
7 au honduras et au nicaragua que la
tragédie est la plus grande
voici ces deux pays avec managua et
tegucigalpa où nous serons en direct
avec nos envoyés spéciaux
alors commençons par nicaragua à 140 km
au nord ouest de la capitale ou non
seulement les glissements de terrain ont
tué des milliers de personnes mais où
l'éruption d'un volcan et un tremblement
de terre ont ajouté un supplément
dramatique reportage qui rit thulliez
parce quelqu'un
pour rejoindre les villages isolés du
volcan cas si tu as il faut emprunter ce
large chemin de terre il ya huit jours
il était répertorié sur aucune carte de
la région et pour cause il n'existait
pas il avait alors dit m plus haut des
champs de canne à sucre le torrent de
boue venue des hauteurs a été si
puissant qu'il a découpé une langue de
terre de plusieurs kilomètres en portant
le bétail et les hommes près de 2000
personnes salomone s'en est tiré mais
pas ses deux frères ni ses neveux depuis
huit jours avec les rares survivants il
côtoie les morts personne ne s'est
préoccupé de leur trouver une sépulture
malgré les risques d'épidémies c'est à
partir d'ici que commencer la commune de
relents de rodrigues cette rivière
disparus faisait office de frontière
et là c'était une autre commune les deux
villages n'existe plus ici il n'y a plus
rien tous les habitants sont morts le
courant était fort avec la boue qui
descendait du volcan tout a été emporté
ma famille je n'ai retrouvé que mon
frère salomon est traumatisée par ce
qu'il a vécu
écoeuré aussi par l'absence des secours
de première urgence
si le lendemain du drame
un hélicoptère venu mais juste pour voir
alors qu'il y avait des enfants et des
vieux qui gémissait aucune brigade de
secours n'est vous ce sentiment
d'abandon est partagé par toute une
région
dans ce village les familles rescapés
ont dû attendre huit jours que la route
soit ouverte pour une première
distribution pour les comprimés dès le
matin dès l'après midi et vous en avez
pour sept jours le risque d'épidémie
n'est pas écartée et l'eau manque
cruellement
si on veut survivre pour parler nous
avons besoin d'eau potable car ici les
pluies n'existe plus il y avait le
village les deux plus artificielles ont
été enterrés
ceux là ont choisi de rester ils
rejoignent leur maison plus haut sur les
flancs du volcan
d'autres noms pêche
ce sont les réfugiés ils sont plusieurs
milliers à paul sotéga dans ce centre
ils s'entassent dans une sorte
d'entrepôt des conditions précaires qui
risque de durer
il est plus nécessaire qu'elle a porté
la science est d'être dans la loge est
un seul endroit où ils seront leurs
pinceaux afin d'éviter les épidémies
mais comment les reloger quand la
principale ville de la région et elle
même sinistre alors beaucoup envisagent
de quitter la terre de leurs ancêtres
cette terre qui les a si longtemps
nourri mais qui aujourd'hui leur à tout
prix
l'une des difficultés les plus
importantes en pareille situation de
catastrophe naturelle est de préserver
les voies de communication or celles ci
ont été en majeure partie détruite
inondé recouvertes de boue dix jours
après les premiers effets du cyclone
voici ce qui reste de la ville de
choluteca
c'est au honduras et de la grande route
qui dessert du nord au sud le pays du
guatemala venant même du mexique et des
états unis
jusqu au nicaragua et descendantes plus
bas tout le long de l'amérique du sud
reportage valérie fournier et avait peu
de sous à la sortie du thé goût cigale
par la capitale la voie est enfin
dégagée
au km 17 pour la première fois la route
s'ouvre aux populations isolées
les dégâts sont impressionnants
il a fallu parfois contournées la
reprise des parts nos cyclos match et
creuser la montagne au km 35
elle rejoint le fleuve le rôle est une
plaine dévasté que contemple encore
incrédule ces enfants qui ont vu partir
leur maison avec les flots là où je me
trouve ça touchant l'un et l'autre là le
seul on est attrait la cuisine
il a une autre chambre d'où ce quartier
huppé des pir edes parle parle t on il
n'ya même plus de cimetière et n'a plus
rien à cirer mais deux neveux ont été
emportées on ne sait pas où ils sont
avec très peu de nourriture ils
continuent de vivre là pour récupérer
leur seule richesse ses tuiles sauver
des housses l'aide arrive mais très
faiblement et tours
au km 80 ces femmes lavent leur linge
dans un filet d'eau qui s'écoule de
l'art est le premier teaser les cultures
détruites et les difficultés
d'approvisionnement en nourriture font
grimper les prix à cet endroit la route
rejoint la panamericana un axe vital qui
traverse tous les initiés par le souffle
de la terre pour faire une sorte de pont
pour que dans l'urgence le principe pas
il remplacera celui ci dont les berges
ont disparu la s'étendait des champs de
canne à sucre la callas venus des
montagnes avec la grue s'y est installée
au km 120 les réfugiés et passe le gain
d'une rivière dont le cours s'est
déplacée d'un kilo mais c'est un vrai
parcours du combattant
après six heures de route
chaumont tk apparaître
première vision des portiques de
balançoire qui dépasse à peine les labos
la boue encore et toujours ici sur les
berges
l'eau atteint le toit le niveau de la
boue est arrivée jusqu'à cet auteur
sahara couvert toutes les rues ça inondé
toutes les maisons n'a jusqu'à la moitié
pour nous c'est très difficile de sortir
la brûlure
c'est une très glissante très mouillée
mouvante le tiers de la ville est dans
cet état
les conditions d'hygiène sont
déplorables et la population n'est pas
près d'oublier cette nuit où le cyclone
est passé
j'ai dû nager beaucoup quand j'étais
prêt la maison de mon ami miranda le
couvrement emporté jusqu'au cimetière
j'ai vu un poteau et je me suis accroché
j'ai encore les marques
quand j'ai vu du monde dans la maison
mon ami alors je me suis lancée pour les
rejets sur le toit et là on a passé la
nuit et 25
ils en ont pour des mois nettoyer avant
de rebâtir
pour eux l'urgence et du sort vivante
le présenter
mais non il n'ya rien à rien on dirait
qu en deux étapes et arriver une
centaine de centres de réfugiés comme
celui ci existe aujourd'hui être choqués
car les réfugiés qui seraient au total
près de 10 me sur la panamericana
choluteca attend toujours de l'aide
la nourriture n'est pas encore arrivé et
la pénurie commence cruellement à se
faire sentir comme dans tout le monde du
raf
ils attendent tous de l'aide
internationale qui tarde à venir
philippe gassot vous êtes à tegucigalpa
la capitale du honduras ou veniez des
états unis où êtes habituellement
correspondant washington quelle a été
votre première impression quant à l'état
la voix sanitaire l'état des hommes des
populations pile état des lieux dans
cette capitale
mais je crois qu'on est passé en
quelques heures d'une d'une profonde
tristesse de ne pas voir arriver là
d'international à l'espoir valérie fonio
vous disait il ya quelques instants
on commence à réouvrir des routes et ici
on avait basé l'international sur sur
l'aviation sur les hélicoptères et vous
savez que les hélicoptères transportent
des charges très faible si on arrive
aujourd'hui et demain à faire passer des
camions
alors là je peux vous dire que l'espoir
va renaître mais pour le moment eh bien
écoutez les l'aide internationale passe
au compte gouttes
ici au honduras on ne peut pas accepter
de gros porteurs ils se posent au
nicaragua et au nicaragua ce sont des
transall de l'armée française qui
relaient et qui viennent déposer ici la
nourriture vous voyez qu'on ne gagne pas
de temps et ensuite ce sont aux
hélicoptères de la distribuer et vous
savez qu'en matière des d'international
il faut tout faire en même temps il faut
que les médecins soient là il faut que
la farine arrive il faut qu'on puisse
cuir la farine
je peux vous dire que si l'espoir renaît
les secouristes ici ne sont pas du tout
au bout de leurs peines en ne le verront
tout à l'heure est-ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que vous avez vu beaucoup de
choses des truites beaucoup de bâtiments
ou de maisons détruites à tegucigalpa
les maisons sont détruites celle qui
borde la rivière ont quasiment disparu
et ce qui est beaucoup plus grave je
vous le disais il ya un instant ce sont
les voies de communication je peux vous
dire que autour de la capitale
je n'ai pas vu un pont qui résistait
c'est à dire que les arbres se sont
engouffrés dans le flou ont formé des
barrages sur les ponts et les ponts ont
été arrachés et ce qui est extrêmement
surprenant c'est de voir des crevasses
qui font jusqu'à 50 mètres de profondeur
c'est vraiment des voies de
communication qui coupe la capitale du
reste du pays
et c'est vraiment là le gros problème
c'est que l'on pourra acheminer des
vivres et bien à ce moment là dans la
population
les conditions sanitaires vont
s'améliorer grandement non on voit sur
ces images l'état des lieux et comment
les habitants de tegucigalpa sont en
train d'essayer de s'organiser aussi
bien pour recueillir un peu d'eau eaux
propres pour cuisiner ou se laver ou
notamment pour les enfants
est-ce que vous avez aussi vu des
personnes qui revenaient de l'étranger
des honduriens des peines des hommes ou
des femmes qui reviennent pour aider
leurs compatriotes bien vous avez ici
un phénomène qu'il faut souligner c'est
un véritable phénomène de solidarité je
veux dire du plus-bas rang social aux
plus élevé vous avez des gens qui
reviennent qui viennent aider je n'ai
pas vu de personnes abandonnées sur le
bord de la route
vous avez les sans abri qui sont
accueillis par un voisin qui sont
accueillis par un cousin et la poignée
de nouilles ou de haricots noirs et
partager je n'ai pas vu des gens faire
ripaille d'un côté et laisser mourir
d'autres personnes de l'autre ceux que
l'on voit parfois dans des cas
semblables
ici les honduriens sont extrêmement
solidaire à tous les niveaux alors
extrêmement solidaire et je crois que
vous avez dans lors de votre votre
voyage en arrivant tegucigalpa vous avez
accompagné une femme qui revenait dans
son pays qui renoue dans son village
eh bien oui c'est une femme qui j'allais
dire appartient une couche aisée de la
population
c'est une femme qui aurait très bien pu
rester
aux états unis où elle se trouvait très
bien elle était en train de d'ouvrir un
atelier le discutaient à boston avec les
représentants de l'art américain et elle
a entendu les informations elle a vu les
informations à la télévision et elle
s'est dit il faut que je retourne chez
moi
elle a ici monter une structure afin de
distribuer un petit peu d'art autour
d'elle et reggina a fait un travail
extraordinaire et c'est un nom qui sera
associé à la solidarité vous allez voir
regina designer est aussi sculpteur
c'est une artiste elle partage son temps
entre l'europe l'amérique et son pays le
honduras que mitch a ravagé elle a
appris la nouvelle quand elle était à
boston le village dans lequel vous
habitez vous savez comment il est ils
m'ont dit qu'il ya quatre maisons qui
sont perdus
mon atelier il est plein avec des lots
et de la terre mais c'est tout ce que je
sais je ne sais pas qui est mort
personne ne sait rien en temps normal
les communications sont déjà difficile
aujourd'hui avec son village
elles sont impossibles sa mère ne pourra
lui donner aucune information pour
savoir il faut y aller et elle sait que
la route est impraticable
avant il lui fallait 45 minutes pour
aller à 100 droite sitôt après l'ouragan
qui a apporté 30 jours de pluie
ininterrompue autant d'eau quand deux
années on ne sait pas pourtant le
gouvernement a fait des efforts les
équipes d'urgence
aussi on travaille 12 heures par jour le
système d est à l'honneur pour rétablir
les communications
le plus vite possible le pays redevient
créatif on trouve les solutions
d'urgence du provisoire qui risque de
durer longtemps
il y avait ici quinze maisons au bord de
la rivière
sur la route il y a des moments où ça ne
passe plus alors on abandonne sa voiture
c'est à dos d'homme que la nourriture
est acheminé les honduriens ont compris
très vite qu'il doive d'abord compter
sur eux mêmes et si l'aide
internationale arrive alors ce sera tant
mieux
entre chaque effondrement 3 6 8 10 km il
n'est pas trop difficile de trouver une
voiture
la solidarité joue les passages seront
gratuits aucun chauffeur ne demande
d'argent
personne ne reste sur le bord de la
route ça va imaginer que c'était comme
ça
imaginez de trois pompes
elle craignait de ne pas revoir son
chien vivant mais n'imaginait pas ça le
centre de 126 tôt disparue quarante
maisons effacés balayer plus d'écoles de
centre social de maisons de soins de
pont de coopératives de café plus rien
rangés le long de la rivière les
constructions pesait un peu penser à
l'italie difficile à imaginer
aujourd'hui
un réconfort cependant dans le désastre
aucune vie n'a été prise la population
avait effectué juste à temps l'atelier
qui donne à san juan sitôt sa réputation
et son dynamisme et aussi quatorze
emplois à résister mais tout est à
refaire
aujourd'hui elle demande de l'aide à
tous ceux qui dans le monde ont besoin
comme elle de mettre de l'art dans leur
vie et dans celle des autres à l'aide
notamment de ceux qui sont venus de
france sont derek marianne fleury
bonjour vous venez de samu 93 jours en
compagnie d'infirmiers médecin
d'épidémiologistes et vous avez
réorganiser tout un dispensaire est ce
que vous pouvez nous dire dans quelles
conditions ça s'est passé
oui mais nous avons installé à dimanche
un dispensaire hier matin dans un
quartier sinistré
de la capitale un quartier qui comprend
à peu près une dizaine de milliers de
personnes et dont le centre de santé a
été complètement détruit donc en trois
quatre heures nous avons installé sous
tente un dispensaire et travailler avec
les médecins et infirmiers locaux qui
ont immédiate et nous avons commencé
immédiatement les consultations dès le
début d'après midi et en quelques heures
jusqu'à hier soir nous avons vu 60
personnes je crois qu'il est important
d'insister sur l'aide du personnel local
c'est fondamental pour tout à fait
puisque nous nous sommes là pendant la
période aiguë eux vont rester et cette
collaboration a été immédiate sans aucun
problème alors est ce qu'il y a des
besoins en termes d de de prévention
d'épidémies pour l'instant où est ce que
pour l'instant vous n'en est pas là
écoutez pour l'instant nous nous
recensons les gastro entérites nous
travaillons avec les épidémiologistes
l'équipe française en particulier qui
est arrivé pour l'instant donc nous
avons quelques indicateurs mais il n'y a
aucun indice
sur la zone que nous couvrons d'épidémie
actuellement je vous remercie
d'autres épidémies oui oui d'autres
épidémies ce talent et si je vous en
prie si vous voulez nous donner d'autres
précisions
oui d'autant épidémiologistes sont
arrivés et donc travail ont mis en
collaboration avec le ministère de la
santé aussi pour bien entendu surveiller
activement le risque d'épidémie puisque
mes pieds
merci beaucoup nous allons maintenant
nous rendre à managua la capitale du
nicaragua hervé brusini quel est le
bilan si tant est qu'on puisse faire un
bilan ce soir dans la capitale du
nicaragua pas vous savez ici claude un
tout dernier bilan justement en clair
d'être publié en août dernier bilan des
victimes
onze mille morts ou disparus c'est un
bilan qui a été revu à la hausse mais il
reste toujours aussi imprécis parce que
lorsqu'on voit cette destruction des
voies de communication on comprend que
tous les sinistrés n'ont pas encore été
localisées comme honduras les sauveteurs
ont été freinés par cette route un
véritable chaos
quarante deux ponts ont été détruits par
l'ouragan mitch alors les 80 hommes de
la sécurité civile française escorté par
olivier galzi et philippe jasselin
essaie tant bien que mal de joindre les
zones les plus reculées
mais on a vu tout c'est toutes ces
images alors le seul ce rôle du secours
français de la sécurité civile au
nicaragua ça se passe comment écoutez ça
se passe comme je voulais expliquer tant
bien que mal ses hommes n'ont pas
énormément de moyens
quoique 16 millions de francs ont été
consacrés par la france et je crois
qu'on va les voir tout de suite en
action
encore une fois filmée par philippe
jasselin et olivier galzi
accueil très chaleureux pour les
français la sécurité civile débarque sur
le volcan casita ici la montagne s'est
effondrée sur les villages alentours de
rétablir l'eau et des taxes l'eau et les
axes légal a commencé
civile locale
on n'a pas les moyens enfin on apprend
même sur les récupérer en or à quoi à
paris en tirèrent
la rend les en purée preuves pour les
faire reconnaître essayez premières
difficultés pour accéder aux sinistrés
la route
dans ce camion de fortune loué pour la
circonstance il faut remonter la coulée
de boue
cette déchirure de la montagne qui a
emporté deux mille personnes il ya huit
jours
que faire pour ces professionnels de
l'urgence quand il ne reste plus rien
que l'odeur de la mort flairé par les
animaux mais on aperçoit des coups
francs les cours comprenant les éléments
importants puisqu'ils permettent de
détecter les victimes qui sont enterrées
sous la boue sur les cochons gratte et
ensuite une fois que les corps sont un
peu en surface les oiseaux tourne autour
pour les corps ils ont laissé des
consignes l'incinération est la
meilleure façon d'éviter les épidémies
à quelques pas de là les français
s'occupent des vivants des miraculés ont
obtenu aussi au rendement tas sur les
flancs de la colline dans ce village
ils sont les premiers secours depuis la
catastrophe
rassemblement de la population à l'école
pour une consultation médicale
on a besoin de nourriture pour les
enfants parce que on a beaucoup de bébés
ici et à une meilleure incroyable
symbole d'espoir dans cet océan de
détresse
celui là au moins n'aura pas vu
l'indicible l'horreur et la peur encore
visibles au fond des yeux des enfants
de plusieurs plaies et qui se sont
barrés de soins avec un médecin par
équipe les 45 hommes de la sécurité
civile arpente ainsi les villages sur le
volcan en tout le médecin capitaine aura
donné une cinquantaine de consultation
ce jour là des français au fin fond du
nicaragua qui font tout simplement ce
qu'ils peuvent
les hommes de la sécurité civile
resteront encore une dizaine de jours
sur les pentes du mont casitas dix jours
à vacciner consulter et panser les
plaies de ces populations qui sont
probablement les plus sinistrées du
nicaragua mais coup de chapeau à ces
zones de sécurité civile car il est bien
difficile d'organiser les secours dans
un pays encore marqué par les
affrontements et rivaux unis entre
sandiniste général ortega les forces
gouvernementales
tout est apaisée politiquement mais
quand même là sa sauce révèle ayez une
polémique précisément au claude
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup la situation
actuelle du nicaragua faut rappeler ce
que le pays a déjà vécu il y a plus de
30 ans le 23 décembre 72 managua été
secoué par un tremblement de terre
trente mille morts les blessures sont
toujours visibles
l'aide internationale était arrivée en
masse elle fut réquisitionné par le
dictateur au pouvoir anastasio somoza
colère du peuple est en 79 à parti
révolutionnaire le front sandiniste
prenait le pouvoir
aujourd'hui les accusations fusent
contre l'actuel président c'est un
libéral
quant aux sandinistes qui sont à présent
dans l'opposition
ils ont même demandé le départ du
président
alors cette colère thierry thulliez et
pascal caron l'ont constaté vous allez
le voir dans les zones les plus
dévastées par l'ouragan
ce dimanche même le prêche du près de
pau sol tega égratigne le gouvernement
la colère gronde dans cette petite ville
du nord-ouest du nicaragua mais c'est
après l'aller il ya une fois sortis de
l'église que les habitants disaient ce
qu'ils ont sur le coeur des lettres
gouvernement traite un peu de fini et
c'est tout alors chaque jour tous se
retrouvent devant la mairie
ils savent que là au moins ils peuvent
récupérer le minimum vital
ce minimum c'est cette femme
le maire de la ville qui leur donne elle
redistribue ce qu'elle reçoit
je sais que ce n'est pas grand chose
mais nous voulons aider
il y a les biscuits du riz des haricots
nous avons tous les jours des gens qui
demandent qu'à manger il enfin mais ce
n'est pas assez parce que nous avons un
satisfaire les demandes tous les
réfugiés ils sont nombreux félicite à
sceller donne est la première à avoir
alerté les autorités sur l'ampleur des
dégâts
sans être entendu par le président
nicaraguayen du coup d'humanitaire la
querelle est devenu politique félicita
appartient au mouvement sandiniste la
gauche d'inspiration révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition ou salt
égaré son fief il n'y a qu'à voir
comment le leader sandiniste daniel
ortega a été accueilli dans les rues de
la ville comme un homme providentiel
défenseur des pauvres contre le
gouvernement c'est un manque de
sensibilité
le président de ce pays est attaché un
programme d'ajustement économique
libéral il veut faire comme si tout
était normal
alors que nous vivons une tragédie sans
précédent au sol tega l'oublier pense
payer son attachement à la cause
sandiniste
comme si le fragile dialogue politique
entre les ennemis d'hier avait été
emportée par l'ouragan mitch
alors bien sûr le gouvernement réagit
avec virulence à toutes ces attaques
la transparence de sa gestion de la
catastrophe est un défi crucial pour ce
pouvoir politique
regardez jean françois hoffman a croisé
la route des plus hautes autorités du
pays
il n'aime pas traverser ce pont là
d'ailleurs tout le pays souffre d'avoir
à passer par cet ouvrage de fortune mais
voilà l'ouragan mitch a cisaillé la
plupart des édifices plus d'un milliard
de francs de dégâts
cette route transamerican traverse toute
l'amérique centrale
l'artère économique du nicaragua et donc
pour leur couper trois cents mètres plus
loin des engins s'activent
réparation express bientôt les camions
pourront à nouveau en jambes et le
fleuve
le ministre des transports supervise les
travaux une bonne occasion pour réfuter
les accusations d'incompétence du
gouvernement à l'arrivée du ragon l'
alerte nationale a bien fonctionné
les gens auraient voulu que l'on décrète
l'état d'urgence et ce n'était pas
nécessaire il suffisait de décider la
catastrophe nationale d'ailleurs
maintenant la communauté internationale
nous aide énormément à l'aéroport de
managua l'aide de l'étranger arrive
enfin on attend encore les hélicoptères
supplémentaires pour acheminer vivres et
médicaments vers le nord mais le beau
temps a permis déjà de nombreuses
livraisons
cette fois c'est le président du
nicaragua en personne qui est en visite
affirmé que l'aide directe aux
sympathisants de son parti accusé son
gouvernement d'être incapable de gérer
la situation tout cela il faut dit-il
tout ce qui était humainement possible
de faire a été fait en revanche on a été
impuissant à rejoindre les zones
sinistrées à un manque de moyens de
communication au coeur même de la
capitale
dix mille réfugiés essaie de vivre dans
ce camp improvisé la municipalité un
bastion de l'équipe au pouvoir envoyer
ses hommes pour distribuer des bâches en
plastique opération est certes
spectaculaire mais les bénéficiaires
sont eux aussi fort critique
insuffisances en eau potable pas
d'électricité on perd managua
il appelle au secours on a besoin d'elle
il faut le soutenir
il faut que quelqu'un donne à quelque
chose grâce à dieu nous sommes en vie et
nous avons toujours nos enfants ce
fatalisme risque de ne pas être partagée
par toute la population du pays
surtout quand on a le ventre creux
puisque nous sommes dans le débat
politique avant de retourner au
nicaragua et le honduras voici quelques
données géographiques et économiques
concrètes permettant de mieux connaître
ces deux pays leurs populations et leurs
difficultés économiques qui les place
parmi les pays les plus pauvres
explications à nos consignes est le
nicaragua contre 4,4 millions
d'habitants son produit national brut
indicateur de la richesse nationale est
de 360 dollars par personne
par comparaison celui de la france est
de 22 mille trois cent soixante quatre
mille nicaraguayen sont morts des suites
de l'ouragan et du glissement de terrain
du volcan casita ce 7000 autres sont
portées disparues
huit cent mille sont sinistrées 70 % des
récoltes sont perdues dont 10% du café
principal produit d'exportation
le président allemann investi en 97 7
ans après la fin de la guerre civile
essuie les critiques des sandinistes
qu'ils accusent d'avoir mal organisé
l'aide aux victimes au honduras ville
5,8 millions de personnes le produit
national brut est de 580 $ par habitant
soit à peu près 60 fois moins qu'en
france
l'ouragan a tué six mille personnes au
honduras 12000 reste aujourd'hui
disparues et deux millions de personnes
soit un tiers de la population sont sans
abri le pays a perdu 120 mille
habitations 70 % du réseau routier et la
quasi totalité de la récolte de bananes
en outre ces pays fragilisés doivent
faire face à des dettes extérieures de
23 et 33 milliards de francs alors l'onu
classe le nicaragua comme le pays le
plus pauvre des amériques après haïti
malgré les aides internationales des
trois-quarts la population se trouve en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
les indices économiques était pourtant
bon puisque l'inflation était plutôt à
la baisse et la croissance plutôt à la
hausse mais hervé bride le cyclone a
tous bouleversés et l'économie est très
très mal parti maintenant ben oui vous
l'avez vu claude le territoire est
dévastée mais l'économie elle elle est à
genoux au marché ce matin
eh bien les habitants de managua
ressentez aussi les effets dus à
l'ouragan le kilo du haricot ou le celui
du riz a quasiment doublé
la culture du café elle a profondément
souffert et la pêche est sinistrée là où
l'ouragan a frappé thierry thulliez et
pascal caron on enfourne très dépaysant
qui ne se pose même plus question sur
leur qu'une pure non ce sur quoi ils
s'interrogent seulement c'est de savoir
s'ils auront de quoi manger demain
c'était la fierté de toute une vie celle
de rossa martinez d'été nario une ferme
prospère la terre est dit-on ici la
meilleure du pays de la canne à sucre
poussé ici depuis des générations
aujourd'hui tout est arrêté à la ferme
nous avons vingt travailleurs au chômage
ils nous ont aidés à retirer le sable
des choses comme ça et il travaille pour
un peu de nourriture car il n'y a pas
d'argent pour les payer
dans la coopérative on tente de sauver
ce qui peut l'être mais l'outil de
travail est hors d'usagé
c'est tout ce qu'il reste des machines
agricoles de l'entreprise je pensais à
émigrer m'en allais honduras au costa
rica pour y travailler car j'ai une
famille et à servir
vous comprenez car ici on peut plus
trouver de travail
ils sont des centaines d'ouvriers comme
ramon n'a pensé partir pour fuir la
famine
étranglé par les dettes les paysans les
plus pauvres ont reçu le coup de grâce
avec l'ouragan ce soir au salvador les
chefs d'état des différents pays touchés
par le cyclone se sont réunis ils font
appel à l'aide internationale et demande
à différents pays dont les états unis et
l'europe de reconsidérer donc leur dette
la france par la voix de monsieur lionel
jospin a fait savoir en concertation et
la présidence de république qu'elle
était prête à alléger la dette et
accroître son aide et puis monsieur
jacques chirac qui avait prévu un
déplacement officiel au mexique et dans
cette région hautement guatemala doit se
rendre également au honduras et au
nicaragua pour constater sur place
là les besoins et les demandes des aides
internationales
la mobilisation internationale s'est
elle peut à peu organisées assez
lentement au départ mais maintenant il
ya notamment une très forte mobilisation
en espagne l'aide européenne serait de
l'équivalent de 140 millions de dollars
mais ceux ci pourraient également être
accrue explication joël bruandet
il aura fallu attendre près de quinze
jours pour que cette nourriture et ses
quelques médicaments parviennent aux
villages les plus éloignés de managua
l'aide humanitaire arrive par la voie d
eau ailleurs c'est l'hélicoptère qui est
le seul moyen d'accès aujourd'hui les
avions qui se posent au honduras et au
nicaragua viennent du monde entier à
bord des centaines de tonnes de matériel
médical de la nourriture et de quoi
rendre l'eau potable
à ce jour les américains ont débloqué
près de 300 millions de francs pour les
pays sinistrés imité par cuba la france
dont l'aide s'élève d'ores et déjà à 25
millions de francs ainsi que l'allemagne
mais la mobilisation la plus
impressionnante est espagnol le standard
de la croix rouge est submergée d'appels
et les convois humanitaires se succèdent
montant de l'aide déjà envoyé 250
millions de francs
tout cela reste malheureusement
insuffisant puisque selon le programme
alimentaire mondial pour effacer les
traces du cyclone le nicaragua et le
honduras ont besoin de dix milliards de
francs on dirait de managua madame
gordana hier guerre vous êtes membre du
pam le programme alimentaire mondial
alors les stocks existent mais le
problème si je comprends bien pour vous
principalement c'est la façon de les
distribuer comment bien les distribuer
vous avez
jean claude s'est pas seulement le
problème de comment distribuer mais
comment atteindre les communistes et qui
reste isoler le programme alimentaire
mondial affiche mobiliser assez
rapidement à cause des stocks que nous
avons dans tout le pays puisque nous
avons une présence de plus de 30 ans
dans les programmes de développement
nous avons aussi fait des achats locaux
en dehors de managua pour les pré
positionnés dans des endroits et qui
s'était moins accessible jusqu'à présent
nous avons aussi ses dérivés plusieurs
bateaux qui allait avec destination à
d'autres pays de la région
mais madame vous pensez réellement que
c'était 2 arrive maintenant à tous les
sinistrés
je pense que la plupart de l'aide arrive
aux sinistrés je pense qu'il est très
important que le public français
comprennent l'envergure de cette
catastrophe
il est à peu près 10% de la population
qui se trouvent sans abri il y à un
quart de la population qui a effet
affectées d'une manière ou d'autre et
les voies d'accès ont été coupées
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait apprécier
l'impact de cette catastrophe sur
l'économie nationale
ces derniers jours il était très
difficile à ne pas penser à macondo de
garcia marquez les gens qu'on a vécu ici
et en faisant un recours les coptes
derrière c'était comme si la terre est
égal et de l'eau et je pense les dégâts
sont sans grand le il ya un retour en
arrière de à peu près 20 ans pense alors
s'il pays est revenu vingt ans en
arrière
combien faudra-t-il de temps pour que il
relève la tête il y aura une première
période d'urgence
on estime que ça va durer à peu près six
mois et ensuite on va entrer dans une
phase de réhabilitation d'à peu près
deux ou trois ans seulement le programme
alimentaire mondial estime course au
cette première phase d'urgence de six
mois il faudra peu près 50 millions de
dollars pour les quatre pays de la
région qui en était le plus touché par
mitch ça ça veut dire que vous espérez
que l'aide internationale durera
longtemps au moins 6 mois vous
six mois c'est pas suffisant si moi
c'est vraiment pour et des agents qui
ont tout perdu et l'ouragan a touché
surtout la partie nord du pays la partie
qui a été touché sévèrement l'année
dernière par l union n'avait l'achète
sécheresse maintenant on a les
inondations six mois c'est pas suffisant
il faut aller au delà
mais vous êtes optimiste sur la
prolongation de cette aide
internationale c'est pas toujours
évident pour tous les pays
je suis optimiste oui parce que comme
vous venez de le mentionner la
transparence gestion du gouvernement et
quelque chose très important et je pense
donc en connaît une gestion transparente
la communauté internationale répondre à
cet appel dead cette transparence c'est
un défi vous pensiez que pour l'heure
cette transparence est respectée
le gouvernement fait beaucoup pour la
respecter par exemple le programme
alimentaire mondial a accès à des
comités qui s'occupe de la programmation
de l'aide alimentaire et d'autres
agences internationales ont aussi cet
accès merci beaucoup merci à remercier
toutes les équipes de france 2 qui aussi
bien honduras au nicaragua nous ont
permis de composer
l'essentiel de cette édition et vous
permettre d'être informés sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment l'amérique centrale
lors si vous voulez répondre aux appels
à la solidarité pour l'amérique centrale
sachez que toutes les chaînes de
télévision françaises ont lancé un appel
commun pour venir en aide aux sinistrés
du cyclone mitch l'aide d'urgence se
fera par l'intermédiaire de la fondation
de france vous voyez un petit peu le
libellé urgence amérique centrale
fondation de france bp 22 75008 paris et
les chèques sont à libeller donc à la
fondation de france
c'est la fin de cette édition
exceptionnelle dans quelques instants le
film de jacques deray clarissa d'après
l'écrivain stefan zweig avec marc et
jusqu'à detmers sully démission de paul
amar d'un monde à l'autre
et puis maintenant ce dernier au revoir
issu de fantômas le fils d'andré
hunebelle un adieu à jean marais celui
qui prétendait s'être toute sa vie amusé
conclusion stupéfiante
il y a plus de mystère fantômas voici le
vrai visage du criminel
c'est lui j'ai bien fait entendre à
oui
ah ah
je ferai pour ton âge nous trouver